du hast mich als dritte frage schon
gefragt ob die figur komplett damit war
und jetzt fragte mich ob ich meine figur
überhaupt lebt mein name ist hier kommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video hier sehr
sehr oft in den kommentaren wünsche von
zuschauern dass die möchten dass ich
irgendwie mal wieder gold teenager
clever bord akinator und das ganze
vielleicht einmal ungeschnitten mache
deswegen habe ich mir für das heutige
video überlegt das sich als erstes
deutsches spielen werde dann werde ich
clever bot spielen dann werde ich
akinator spüren das ganze ungeschnitten
also kleider zwischen wertig schneiden
aber nicht in den jeweiligen video als
erster spieler ja gar schon gebracht hat
gott die mir leid
wir haben hier eine tante die mit naja
ok sie läuft einfach in mich rein
wahrscheinlich bin ich dann auch noch
schulter gut kann ich die nicht
irgendwie an weg denn er steht da
einfach um und spielt verstecken mit hey
ich hab ihn nicht weiter
jetzt kann er wieder nicht wahr sein
leute ich werde übrigens den ton also
die musik werde ich mich etwa nicht hoch
die musik werde ich schon schneiden als
ich werde schon in manchen situationen
mobile aufwenden muss wird nicht auf
denn was ist denn los wieder hat denn
jeder die hand in die am kopf er spielt
verstecken wie hier keine ahnung was die
machen ja hier bereit die mit ok legt
euch dahin alles klar dann nicht auch
irgendwie im stall drin was der band auf
dem glücklichen paar spiele da freilich
nicht gar nichts mehr und das hier ist
wirklich eines der spiele wo das der
fall ist also hallo kamel
du hast aber schöne fehler und da bin
ich und stecke meinen kopf um dadurch
naja gut
also ich hab mir vorgenommen dass ich
jedes spiel von circa vier minuten
spieler dann haben wir einen tollen mix
werben 12 13 15 minuten video ich denke
doch ganz schön dass videospiele bin ich
jetzt hin gefallen hätte ich verstehe
wirklich gar nicht wenn er beim video
kommt übrigens heute mit den später wenn
er verurteilt wird wahrscheinlich schon
9 uhr
das liegt einfach daran herr polizei
aber nicht einig was ist da drin alter
und da fische
junge sie liegen einfach fischer auf dem
boden weiter fort die polizei ist auf
jeden fall der freund und helfer
ich bitte sie
ich habe auch nur einen fisch gegessen
es tut er zieht mich einfach mit
wohin mit den laufenden über die mauer
rüber also ich komme wieder auf den
punkt das video kommt ein bisschen
später wenn ich heute abend mit heute
abend auch im winter war ich hab so
viele von euch getroffen alter war
unfassbar um so viele hatten merge an
von mir und hat einen pocket und ich
habe auch wiederholt filme
unterschrieben und auch schuhe und die
bilder gemacht jedoch echt krank gewesen
also aber ich weiß nicht wo er mich hier
gerade hier ehrlich gesagt bin da gerade
so ein bisschen skeptisch ob er
überhaupt einen fiat weil ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob diese ob dieses spiel
wirklich der polizeistation oder
ähnliche fahrt aber jetzt ist gerade
werden schmeckt aber ich würde sagen
nach dieser rede wert wird er mich
hingezogen hat machen wir dann weiter
mit dem zweiten spiel da steht ein
zweiter offener dafür polizei karre
werden auf die polizei kale über die
polizei caritas direktor des centre wir
haben hier habe trotz die polizei heute
da fordert wirklich die politik derzeit
wir warten mal ab ob er mich rottweil
okay wenn jetzt schneiden würde könnte
ich hatte schöne blumen aber okay ich
warte erstmal ab passiert passiert für
den titel in und wahrscheinlich werde
mich jetzt ein oder oder nicht also hey
leute ich wollte gerade von der polizei
abgeführt die habe ich jetzt die rein
getan und jetzt gar nicht wieder raus
laufen also
auf jeden fall danke für deine leistung
lieber politisch darf wartet sie mit
deutschtümelei und ich würde sagen wir
machen direkt weiter mit dem clever bord
wir befinden uns jetzt hier bei den
clever bord und ich würde sagen gefangen
direkt an mit einer normalen frage wie
geht ihr einfach mal so als breakers ein
bisschen als wie geht's dir gut okay er
versteht es anscheinend nicht
dann würde ich sagen frage ich ihn
einfach nochmal wie geht es hier
vielleicht hatte das apostroph nicht
verstanden englisch okay für konnte oder
deutsch reden
ich frage ihn aber auch deutschland
kannst du keinen in deutsch mehr regeln
fragezeichen noah kaan ok ich weiß nicht
warum er irgendwie auf ihn geschrieben
aber ich probiert man einfach mit hallo
hallo ist somit das einfach darauf
deutet heute dann schreib doch was
bedeutet weil ich weiß wirklich nicht
was halten soll ein plan auf einmal kann
er wieder deutsch reden meine damen und
herren das ist wieder typisch paperport
erst welche die ganze zeit lagern vom
wegen öl blablabla aber ich gehe jetzt
mal einfach auf zink formiert hatten wir
tatsächlich glaube ich noch nie so okay
ich mache mir da kommt er wieder jahr
wie versteht dass gerade gar nicht genau
aber ich schreibe weiter mein name luca
hallo lea okay okay dass die leute mich
jetzt schneiden und einfach das video
schon beenden aber irgendwie ist der
wohl keine ahnung ich sag hallo mein
name ist luca und er sagt einfach hallo
lena gibt nein ich habe lieber clever
bot hallo alex okay okay so langsam sind
wir wirklich an vom punkt angekommen da
muss ich wirklich sagen super
dafür ist jetzt komplett beschützen
geworden hier meine fresse erst bin ich
lehrer dann bin ich leg ich war mal
wieder nein ich habe
luca und als ok ihr vorgänger
sabi sabi willst du mich verarschen
clever wort alter da fragten mich doch
leute die so ich treffe aber nicht mehr
so oft hochladen
mein gott und mit nein
ich heiße lukla punkt pom pom lieber
karabag schöner name
was bedeutet das ok der wm luca bedeutet
sage ich mal
nein es bedeutet stupid der clever was
sagt dass ich dumm bin und das sagt er
diesmal nicht in die verschlüsselt oder
impliziert dass sich in welcher an und
aussagen ein erwachsenes trade in die
fresse dass ich bleiben
lieber clever bot
aber wir warten aber direkt weiter
das ist nämlich auch vom gros ich war
mal was hältst du von diesem video also
von dieser idee ich meine ich find's
cool da sie für drei sachen nicht klar
da soll noch einer sagen clever bord und
ich passen zusammen bin ich eher nicht
ja
mit dem clever bot
das geht gehörig den bach runter freunde
mit dem clever bot in achim einfach mal
würde mit mit mit bier geht es den bach
runter clever bord doch was hat darauf
zu antworten nein mir geht es ganz gut
was tue ich hier würde du die würden
video einen daumen hoch geben frage ich
ihn mal und jetzt bin ich gespannt auf
die antwort ob er mich komplett fit nein
habe ich nicht
wie denn auch das wie das doch okay das
video ist schon draußen wenn ihr gerade
weht aber naja wir können auf jeden fall
bei accuweather festhalten ich wurde von
der polizei abgeführt und wurde in den
knapp gebracht beim clever bord können
wir sagen er hält mich für studium und
würde ich auf jeden fall nicht einlassen
wenn ihr andere meinungen seit würde ich
nicht auf jeden fall über den live
freuen wenn ihr nämlich bock auf die wg
hat also ich werde gleich noch akinator
spielen keine sorge
aber wenn ihr wollt dass ich das
wirklich öfters machte zb irgendwie
einmal in der woche oder so dass sich
clever bord akinator und milito 73
sachen drei browsergames mehr oder
weniger oder normale geld webseiten wie
früher main kanal geprägt haben durch
werte gefunden habe der für die zusammen
ein video packe und dazu an kant
hochladen oder vielleicht geschnitten
schreibt hört einfach in die kommentare
oder das leid da und ich würde sagen
jetzt weiter mit akinator wird hierbei
magnaten auf meine damen und herren wir
haben schon wieder ukulele hier drin
also ich weiß nicht ich habe da wirklich
schon lang nicht mehr hochgeladen aber
irgendwer sich anscheinend immer noch
gesucht
ich nehme mir einfach als altar mein
alter ein wurde deine figur durch
youtube berühmt an wen denken wir denn
überhaupt meine damen ich würde sagen
wir suchen erst mal mich wurde deine
figur durch youtube berühmt ja schmidt
eine figur minecraft ich würde mal sagen
ja falls der kanal der figur crafter ja
vega
der akinator hat mich schon gefragt ob
der kanal name kaum schafft und es fällt
mir noch eine frage
ich dachte geschaffen jetzt wirklich
neue rekord mit drei fragen aber leute
gar nicht mag deine figur kann youtube
ja jeder übt kritik also ich mach jetzt
nicht in videoform häufig aber tut mal
sagen ja hat eine figur ein baten eine
band über nebencharakter nein sie kommen
nicht auf jedes australien di martino
popcorn ja liefert übrigen bücher
wahrscheinlich nicht mag eine bratwurst
ja mag ich hab' ich glaube er wird
leider auch deswegen gleich mal nein
kommt eine pivot es von ihrer facebook
nein hat er nicht über schwarzfahren
nein
willst du mich verarschen du hast mich
als dritte frage schon gefragt ob die
figur computer ist damit ja und jetzt
fragt er mich ob ich meine figur
überhaupt lebt mega-hits mich verraten
lebt den äthiopier gelände bewegen wir
okay liegt die tu wien ihr nein
trägt eine maske nein matte juli buch
architekten eine trial
[Musik]
apa
alter
wieso leute es ist nicht konnte also ist
rausgekommen sondern ritter von konrad
master bilder oder master bilderfolge
ich nochmal nein ich fahre ford hat eine
tiguan album ja wohl einen kontrakt über
ein jahr konnte mir deine die korea mit
drogen nein ja also ich bring cup und
tomaten bierchen oder sind auch drogen
aber jetzt nicht so weil sie nicht teile
oder irgendwie keine ahnung gras oder
irgendwas also das nicht mag deine figur
socken
was hast du ne frage er mensch markt
locken denn im sommer geburtstag hinein
gehört dann die biografie als die
weiblichen ein markt wie gemacht eine
biologie der platz bleibt
ich habe zwei videos zwischen
hochgeladen und früher auch mal mich
würd mal sagen ja hat deine figur schon
mal beim vfb stuttgart gespielt ich
finds auch hanna die wir da von der
frage wirklich wir müssen uns noch
insekten für die dritte frage war ist
seine figur kaum schlagbar und ich habe
mit ja geantwortet und es geht immer
noch weiter leute also irgendwie immer
was ganz gehörig nicht nein hat sie
nicht eine figur spielt der typ und
minecraft utopia mit ich weiß nicht was
das ist ist eine figur ein mädchen ein
wenn wie geplant von experten ein
komplettes leipzig nein er hat seine
koffer gepackt nein reine biophilia denn
dort classic nein damit stand eine
geburt ein videospiel höhe
denn figur ein helm buchstaben auch eine
blonde thaya nicht verlobt ja ich habe
mir tausend abonnenten ich habe einen
habe ich lange nachnamen diesen lagern
aber definiert scheiße
ich glaube ich habe
gleich abgeholt wird
nein zum hut auf die kamera mittel
umgestellt folglich habe verpackt im
schnitt habe ich nicht verkauft habe ich
habe jetzt gerade verkackt weil ich
dachte ich würde jetzt schneiden alter
scheiße also ich wollte mit akinator
jetzt aufhören gerade weil die vier
minuten voll sind aber aic nicht mal
nicht leiden kann ich das was ihr vom
video meine damen und herren wenn euch
die idee gefällt und ihr das öfter sehen
wollen dann hat man leichter und bei
ich weiß ich habe sich da vielleicht
schaffen kann aber sind flugrouten
natürlich können wir es schaffen
irgendwie bin ich bei martin a
tatsächlich nicht auf mein profil
gekommen ich weiß nicht was überhaupt
noch existiert oder ob das schon viele
aufrufe hat oder zu viele spieler oder
keine ahnung was aber ist auch komplett
egal findet jetzt beide eingeblendet
wenn die daraufhin könnt ihr einen kanal
abonnieren
dort oben findet ihr auch meinen job
eingeblendet wo im netz kaufen konnten
könnt und in acht tagen fand im dritten
reich sogar ein neuer rudi und hier
findet ihr irgendein anderes video
effekte sagte